give ramsey is the hottest sexiest
action star in the world when I think I
can't Ramsey in this Avalanche movie I
get very comfortable yeah well I'm not
gonna get into a bidding war with finest
Avocet because you know even if Kip
Ramsey's interested you know we might
not want kit Ramsey don't believe this
now they try to tell us who's gonna be
in our movies yeah give me kid you
didn't know you didn't know you didn't
hear me when I said very important this
morning what good are you do you have a
brain do you want to keep this job
shut up listen learn your disappointment
disillusion you you you are a worthless
yeah isn't this turning into an
intelligent conversation loud nasty
that's the only way it sticks Don know
how much I've missed all of you and I
promise you I'll never desert you again
because I have to salomi will make
another picture run another picture you
see this is my life it always will be
nothing else
cameras and those wonderful people out
there in the dark all right mr. DeMille
I'm ready for my close-up the book has
no story there's no story all right make
one up I mean nobody in this town can
make up a crazy story like you you're
the king of that it's someone else's
material I have a responsibility to
Susan anyway I wanted to grow as a
writer I want to do something simple
show people how amazing flowers are are
they amazing I don't know yes my new I
thought it was doing the thing he was he
quit
my coop which is I could are fired what
the Mike it's usually both Mike
moonshiner Jake oh my gosh have you
known my trainer
we share a vagina I think it wouldn't do
it mm-hm how do you know cuz he told me
you want to do it
Jake Jake yessum asked me if you sells
tickets fine does he sounds like a t
sells a shitload of tickets and don't
ask me if the theater critics love of
the theater critics or they walk to
spooge on him I want you to go back to
work tomorrow
you were recasting the lead actress
anyway audition many girls for the part
when you see the girl that was shown to
you earlier today you will say this is
the girl the rest of the cast can stay
that's up to you but that lead girl is
not up to you
that's what he said I was associate you
must bring something heavy to the deal I
do me
it says here you getting Martin we're
for the part of Lovejoy
that's right we're getting Martin camera
how you gonna do that I'm gonna take a
gun I'm gonna put it to his head I'm
gonna say son of papers Martin are you
dead thing but if I'm crying crying call
it man you can cry oh I know let's let's
make lemonade okay yeah I don't know if
four-leaf would say that would you four
leaf will you cry when your hands blew
up
no now we're rewrites
right were you going to rewrite it
Jackson Jackson can't cry the sun's
going down
yes my dear but please remember around
tones Pierre you shouldn't have come
Pierre you shouldn't have come yes yes
my dear that's much better than hold it
a second I mean look here's the mic
right here in the bush you know now you
talk towards it the sound goes through
the cable to the box
a man records it on a big record in wax
but you have to talk into the mic first
in the bush